لسنوات سعت الشركات الاوروبيه العامله في
مجال الصناعات الدفاعيه لزياده حصتها من
سوق الانفاق الدفاعي حول العالم
[تصفيق]
منذ اندلاع الحرب في اوكرانيا بات هناك
تزايد كبير في الانفاق الدفاعي سواء هنا
في الشرق الاوسط او حتى في اوروبا لكن الى
اي مدى الشركات الاوروبيه لديها القدره
على التعامل مع تنام الطلب على المنتجات
الدفاعيه ولماذا هناك بعض الدول تفضل
الشركات الامريكيه مقارنه بالشركات
الاوروبيه حول هذا الموضوع معنا كاران
مدير عام شركه ساب السويديه في دوله
الامارات العربيه المتحده اولا السيده ان
شكرا على وجودك معنا هنا في الاستوديو
بدايه رئيس التنفيذي لشركه ساب تحدث مؤخرا
عن انه شركه ساب تسعى لزياده مبيعاتها هنا
في الشرق الاوسط وتحدث عن انه مبيعاتكم
فقط 10% من اجمالي مبيعات سب لماذا هذا
الرقم المحدود وكذلك هذا الامر هل له
علاقه بالقدرات التصنيعيه لشركه ساب ام
بسياسات محدده تفرضها الحكومه في السويد
بدايه اشكركم على الاستضافه من دواعي
سروري ان اكون معكم بالحديث عن سبب فنحن
شركه سويديه واصبحنا شركه عالميه لكننا
بجذور سويديه والسوق الام لشركتنا كانت
السوق السويديه على مدى سنوات عديده اما
حاليا وكجزء من استراتيجيه ساب اصبحنا
نسعى لاستكشاف اسواق جديده عالميا لخدمه
مصالح الشركه والشرق الاوسط واحد من هذه
الاسواق التي نسعى لزياده التركيز عليها
ولذلك اشار المدير التنفيذي لساب الى ان
الشرق الاوسط احد مراكز اهتمام الشركه
لدينا وجود رسمي في الامارات وفي دول اخرى
في المنطقه لكننا نامل ان نحقق المزيد من
التوسعاده فيما يتعلق بالخطه التي تعملون
عليها لزياده مبيعاتكم هنا في الشرق
الاوسط ما هي تفاصيل او ملامح هذه الخطه
بالنسبه لساب فقد كان حضور النشط في
المنطقه منذ ثمانينيات من خلال بيع
منتجاتنا ونعمل حاليا على زياده حضورنا
وهذه خطوه حكيمه وبوسعنا هنا التحدث عن
الامارات كمثال اذ بدانا بمكتب تمثيل
لمجموعه من مسؤول المبيعات في ابوظبي ومن
ثم كانت الخطوه التاليه عبر اقامه شركه مع
شريك اماراتي محلي وقبل سنوات اتخذنا خطوه
اضافيه بافتتاح شركه اجنبيه على ارض
الامارات نقوم من خلالها بالاعمال
الهندسيه وتطوير المنتجات وتجهيز المصانع
واعدادها ومن ثم تقديم الدعم على المستوى
الاقليمي كما ان المنتجات التي نقوم
بتطويرها هنا هي جزء من المحفظه الكامله
لساب وكذلك على صعيد السوق العالميه هذه
واحد من الطرق التي نتبعها لتوسيعتها
حصتنا من السوق الاقليميه الى جانب حصتنا
في السوق فنحن نسعى للتقارب مع القطاع
الاكاديمي واقامه علاقات شراكه مع شركات
في المنطقه ولتحقيق ذلك بنجاح نحتاج لوجود
شركه ثابته لنا في المنطقه هذه هي حقيقه
استراتيجيتنا من اجل زياده حصتنا في اسواق
الشرق الاوسط
هل تركزون في هذه المرحله على تسويق
منتجات فقط ام انكم كذلك تسعون الى مساله
شراكه مع دول منطقه الشرق الاوسط لانه
لدينا الان في منطقه الشرق الاوسط الكثير
من الدول التي لا تسعى فقط لمجرد مبيعات
ولكن كذلك تسعى لتاسيس صناعات دفاعيه خاصه
بها اذا طلب من ساب المشاركه في مساله نقل
التكنولوجيا ونقل الافكار هل توافقون
ولديكم استراتيجيه تتماشى مع رؤيه هذه
الدول في هذا المنطق
نعم لدينا استراتيجيه خاصه لذلك وهي قائمه
على ان نقل المعرفه التكنولوجي السريه هو
امر يشكل جزءا من سياده الدول بغض النظر
عن الدوله التي نمثلها وبالتالي اعمل على
حمايتها
استراتيجيهنا هنا في الشرق الاوسط هي
البدء في بناء هذه المعرفه وبالطبع حسب
اسلوب ساب بتنفيذ اعمالها سواء العمليات
الاجرائيه او القوالب المعده مسبقا اي
طريقه انجازنا لاعمالنا بشكل عام فنحن نرى
اننا تعلمنا علما اننا ناتي من دوله صغيره
بميزانيه محدوده حيث ان السويد دوله صغيره
نسبيا بتعداد سكان عشره ملايين تعلمنا ان
نعمل بذكاء وكذلك بكفاءه عاليه ناهيك عن
مساله التعاون مع شركاء اخرين سواء
الشركات الحكوميه العامله في هذا القطاع
او المؤسسات الاكاديميه وهذا نراه ايضا
احد النجاح لكن الاساس هو اقامه الشركه
هنا ومن ثم استقطاب الموارد البشريه
المناسبه والاصول اللازمه واخيرا تطبيق
طرق عملنا هنا وبالنظر لمجمل اعمالنا نحن
في النهايه لا نريد ان نتنافس مع انفسنا
عالميا بل نراعي ان تكون المنتجات التي
نطورها هنا متناسبه مع المحفظه العالميه
الكامله لمنتجات الشركه هذه هي حقيقه
استراتيجيتنا
منذ بدايه الصراع في اوكرانيا بات هناك
تنامي كبير في الطلب على المنتجات
الدفاعيه سواء هنا في الشرق الاوسط او حتى
في اوروبا وكذلك على مستوى العالم لكن
يعني الملاحظه طبقا للتقارير التي صدرت
مؤخرا بانه هناك زياده في الطلب على
المنتجات الدفاعيه من الشركات الاوروبيه
الامريكيه مقارنه بالشركات الاوروبيه
لماذا هذا الامر
بدايه علي القول ان الحرب هي كارثه بحق
الانسانيه والرؤيه الخاصه لساب هي حق
الانسان في الشعور بامان وعندما نرى اي
نزاعات مثل تلك الحرب القريبه من بلادنا
بين اوكرانيا وروسيا فهي بمثابه تاكيد على
حق الامم في ان تكون قادره على ان تدافع
عن نفسها وتحقيق الاستقرار والسلام وهذه
مسائل اساسيه ومحوريه لتحقيق الاستدام
البيئيه الى جانب امور كثيره اخرى مهمه
للبشريه والان ونحن نواجه هذا الوضع
الجيوسي الذي يكتنفه الغموض ليس اوروبيا
فقط بل عالميا ايضا لهذا نرى هذا الطلب
المتزايد ليس من امريكا فقط بل من
الاوروبيين كذلك وكثير من الدول رفعت
ميزانيتها الدفاعيه نعم نحن نشهد زياده في
الطلب بشكل عام وما نقوم به في ساب هو رفع
قدراتنا التصنيعيه لتلبيه الطلب